le gymnase chantal mauduit à magny les
hameaux toujours fermé et jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
le 11 octobre dernier le auvent s'est
affaissé sur environ 50 centimètres
depuis pour des mesures de sécurité le
gymnase a été fermé dès était ont été
posés pour consolider la structure un
bureau de contrôle est venu jeudi
dernier vérifier la solidité du
dispositif
mais en attendant d'obtenir par écrit la
vie du cabinet de contrôle
la mairie a choisi de ne pas rouvrir la
structure sportive
la ville ne connaît pas encore les
raisons de l'affaissement de l'auvent
des experts devront se prononcer
le gymnase construit en 1999 a déjà
connu d'autres incidents notamment un
déplacement de façade en 2009 lors du
passage de la tempête